i think this is a beautiful uh beautiful
reality you have created yeah the only
thing that's missing is uh david caruso
from csi miami no but no what he's
saying is way harder than anything csi
has ever had to tackle i'm looking to
see a sign now oh you all got it easy
let me change channels you guys make
this cs
tv show no we need the dps
oh my gosh
[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and i
got chuck nice with me as usual chuck
baby
hey neil what's happening all right very
good very good you know we got a really
deep subject today oh my gosh which is
why i was trying to figure out why i'm
here
[Laughter]
when i saw the actual uh copy for the
show i was i was like i think they got
did i receive this by mistake
using using forensic science to identify
missing soldiers yeah oh my gosh very
important work and of course i mean why
wouldn't this be a thing right i mean
you know we got forensics for crime we
got you know we got dna for for
exoneration and it seems like there's a
lot of bits and pieces there you put it
all together
in one sort of scientific chemistry
biology
uh
uh work universe and so the department
of defense has an entire branch of
itself that specializes in just this and
we've got two guests today who will take
us deep into what those operations are
how they work and what their success
rates are and they'll just just keep us
up to date on
what has been happening over these
recent years as it tracks the progress
of science and leading off we've got dr
tim mcmahon tim welcome to star talk
well neil thank you chuck nice to meet
you as well it's uh it's an honor for me
to be here and chat with you on dna
excellent thank you you're a biomedical
scientist and director of the dod
department of defense dna operations so
of course that's got to be a thing so
so first time in black tim i got to tell
you
well you know i'll get i'll give you men
in blue since blue suits are my
favorites
and and also
for those who can see this in video um
tim is wearing a vibrant red tie so that
that's not men in black uniform for sure
uh but let me ask the the defense
prisoner of war and missing an action
accounting agency that's a mouthful what
can you tell us about that
so so the dpaa um is actually they're
the organization that is in charge with
the recovery and identification of the
missing service members
i uh my organization is the armed forces
medical examiner system and we're
actually partnered with the dpaa
we actually provide all dod with human
remains dna identification so not only
for the past accounting mission
where we helped the dpa identify our
fallen heroes from world war ii korea
vietnam
and the cold war but also all of our
current day losses as well
and you know you were talking about dna
and crime
you know the first time dna was used in
a criminal case was in 1987 in england
in 1991 the military used dna for the
first time to assist with the
identification
of a service member from vietnam but
also with current day losses at the cl
at the close of operation desert storm
of the first gulf war
that actually set up our laboratory and
established the dna laboratory under the
armed forces medical examiner system
excuse me it's not just uh remains in a
bat in a battlefield there are places
where
where fallen soldiers have been buried
anonymously right we think of you know
the beaches of normandy i'm just
thinking you know korea cambodia vietnam
not every place is just here's a box of
remains go to work it's got to be more
complicated than that isn't it
it is much more complicated um and my uh
cohort at the dpa uh dr franklin damon
who you'll be chatting with uh
he will be able to give you a much more
in-depth uh on that but they we we are
mandated uh by the united states
government you know we we leave no man
behind and so um
the uh there's been active recoveries uh
for example for vietnam since the uh
close of the vietnam war
um and then with korea and world war ii
but for example in our own cemetery uh
in the uh national memorial cemetery the
pacific in hawaii
there are unknown service members who
were recovered but could not be
identified
the those are the dna samples for one
set of
uh types of remains called disinterments
that come to my lab
that we will test
and
and obtain the dna out of those and then
run a couple of different tests on them
but
unlike a modern crime scene where for
example if i committed a crime they
could take a swab from my cheek and they
could do that direct reference that way
we don't have that ability so we
actually have to rely on family members
to donate samples to us that we can then
compare to these unknowns to assist with
the identification effort so when you
exum well i i suppose you don't need to
exhume an entire body because if it's
dna you only need a sample
and then what do you do from there you
create a database or do you create a
familial database and then work
backwards
so that's that chuck that's actually an
excellent question um we
we have proactively been collecting
references since 1992 so for example for
the original 8100 missing at the end of
the korean war
i have family references in a database
for 92 percent of those missing so we do
have that family reference database for
vietnam we're at about 86 percent
uh and then world war ii was recently
added in about 2010 um and so we have
about 18
of the original 72 000 missing
um but
if you look at for example the uss
oklahoma
there were 390 but just remember
oklahoma
that's in pearl harbor so
december 7th 1941 the ship sank with
servicemen inside
the ship entombing them is that i
understand this correctly okay and then
the ship was righted and those remains
were recovered and they were interred in
the national memorial cemetery the
pacific as unknowns
for the uh for in my lab we received uh
363
out of 394
uh
references so we had references for 363
of those which once you start getting
really over 80 percent coverage
dna becomes a strong supporting line of
evidence for identification but chuck to
answer your question when we disinter
you're going to hear from my esteemed
colleagues
all about the excellent work that they
do and it's not just dna dna is one
means of identification
it's about
all of the information coming together
for example their stature which is
anthropology and there's dental and and
there's historical evidence and things
like that so it's about building the
full picture i'm just one cog in that
picture which is the dna portion of it
oh okay but how do you but so when
normally when we think of bones we don't
think of dna we think of like you said
cheek samples or skin samples or so
but
there is sort of living was living
tissue inside of bones
uh at some point in their history is
that where you get the dna because
otherwise the calcium i don't think
would be very helpful
no so you're absolutely right so
um the the actual um osteocytes which is
the formal word for the the dna
containing cells within the bone
that dna is protected and so
we actually can take a portion of the
bone and grind that bone up into a
powder
and then we add a buffer to it
we call it demineralization buffer it's
a big word but i want you to think of
turpentine if you drop turpentine on the
hood of your car you dissolve that paint
completely well this well do i know that
so
that buffer dissolves that bone powder
completely and frees up all of the dna
but when we do that
in that liquid now is
not only human dna there's bacterial dna
there's fungal dna anything that was in
the environment that could have soaked
into that bone as well over time wow and
so we have to we have to purify the dna
and what i tell people the most is you
think about that last cup of coffee
nobody wants to drink of all the grinds
in it
if you were to pass that coffee back
through a filter the grinds would stay
on top and you get the pure coffee well
we have a specialized filter that the
dna binds to and we can wash away
everything we don't want
but then
which way that's being that's being very
clever i mean presumably you didn't have
that initially and someone said i have
an idea uh i have dna
velcro okay yeah so right so no this i
mean you know
you're speaking like yeah this is there
but oh my gosh people are inventing this
stuff all along and it is so the
earliest point that you know dna was
identified was 1950s
it was in the 60s that the first
purification methods came out but it
wasn't that filter didn't come around
until 1984
and now we can actually use magnets we
can bind the dna to a special particle
and then use a magnet to pull the dna
out of it
more about that that's that's just okay
that's sci-fi insane right there
so okay please do just that process for
a second uh you know okay and then neil
can tell me can you magnetize anything
no i'm going to presume tim means that
it's a chemical magnet and magnet is
metaphorical i'm going to assume that
tim correct no so actually oh ow okay
don't say any more because you're you're
top secret clearance
actually it's a small sphere
that is charged
and it it then has a it has a
a special binding agent that allows the
dna to bind to it based on a charge
and because it's metal you can then hold
a magnet against the side of the tube
and that pulls the that metal sphere
with the dna to it
and then we can wash away everything
else
and then you rehydrate the dna at that
point and that breaks the bond off of
that sphere and you get the pure dna oh
my that's cr okay it's called science it
is called science but i'm going to tell
you and no disrespect to the process or
the importance of it but they do the
same thing with cocaine
are you serious i'm dead seriously
it is a chemical process you know and
the easiest way i tell people is you
know when we grew up there was that that
little um that little toy that looked
like the face and you had the magnet had
the meg the ferrous metal in there and
you could draw the beard on it yeah
that's what we're doing is you're
basically buying the dna and then
putting a magnet and pulling it out that
way
fascinating yeah and chuck i i didn't i
ko i didn't know that about cocaine you
know yeah i mean i have no sense it's
not exactly that because you know uh
as much money as you know these drug
dealers have they don't they don't want
to spend it on science all i know is
that drug dealers were metric fluent
before anyone in the united states was
and so
that's true they're selling kilos and
things that is a true statement so
so uh so tim is there a um
are who who
i know there's a lot of research not
only in private industry but also in the
dod so who is leading the dna frontier
today
is is it your your kind of research
because you've got deep government
pockets for that or is it 23 and me
right where because that's a
because that's a entire commercial
enterprise that's driven by market
forces so uh neil that's a great
question it's actually a combination of
both
so when you uh so we do the exact same
tests that your state and local and the
fbi do for criminal case work because
any unidentified human remains that are
found in the local fall underneath your
local police jurisdiction so that's
where
you see they're using these commercial
tests and now you see through
investigative what's called
investigative genetic genealogy
where they're able to utilize uh
uh what we call direct-to-consumer
companies
where they can then use build off of the
23andme and ancestry.com
and
guide police into identifying either a
cold case perpetrator of a crime or an
unknown person who died and they had no
way forward
the difference is those are geared
toward modern dna samples these are dna
samples that have been protected over
the years
we have to take
either what's
been commercially developed break it and
make it work for ours that have been in
the environment 80 plus years have seen
chemical insults from being
prepared for burial or from
post-traumatic fire from a crash in an
airplane
or in a lot of it i call it fit for use
we have to develop that test so the
police and the 23andme they're
collecting samples for the purposes of
identification and uh lineage whereas
you guys have to create that yourself
right
so what what what the police do is if
you have a coat case
and they've isolated dna let's say from
an unknown human remains so this is an
individual that was found in the woods
the police get it they develop a profile
they then search the fbi's missing
person database it doesn't hit to it the
investigators have no leads it's now a
code case they can work with companies
like orthrum and parabond and a lot of
other direct-to-consumer companies out
there
to develop
this what we call a single nucleotide
polymorphism profile which is your
ancestry markers your identity markers
and then they can search
gedmatch which is a a searchable
database and they can identify
potential leads of who this person may
be
and then the police investigators will
investigate they will find
and then if they find a reference they
will collect a reference from that
person match it and then make an
identification that way every day that
goes by the data base gets better for
everybody
in in in the commercial sector yes the
more people that get in there the better
the database gets but for our case
we we have already developed that
database but those commercial assays
won't work with ours so for example what
i tell people is
if you and i'm a knuckle jagger from
from being a mechanic when i was younger
in school is i was there when we
switched from standard sockets to metric
sockets whoa
and so i hear the drug dealers had that
same kind of uh they did you know they
had to start figuring out how to go from
pounds to kilos
so
but
you know if you have a standard socket
that's a 7 16 a 10 millimeter may work
on it once but then it'll strip it and
so what we have to do is we have to
make that test to work so for example
the chemically treated samples so at the
end of the korean war as part of
operation glory the united states
received
about 4 000 sets of remains about 850 of
those could not be identified they were
buried in the national memorial cemetery
the pacific and hawaii is unknowns
when
the dpa went in disinterred we could not
get a dna result from them and it took
16 years and science to catch up
but in 2016
we developed and validated a method that
allowed us to get dna results from it
using what we call next generation
sequencing that's those instruments that
you hear about personalized medicine
yeah so we adapted we adapted from the
medical side brought it in
created a test that is not commercially
available
and since 2016 we've gone from seven
samples a month
to over 70 samples a month and went from
a 20 success rate to over 68 success
rate just with that
and it's led to over 200 and uh over 200
new identifications for people who
previously would not have worked because
the commercial test like 23andme and
ancestry.com or the commercial short
tandem repeat tests which are the
markers your state and local crime labs
use wouldn't work we've had to make them
work with our type samples and just so
just to remind people you you mentioned
uh did you say customize medicine or
just i want to just remind people that
we can imagine a future where
you the medicine you are prescribed
knows about your entire dna profile so
that you can minimize side effects and
have the medicine do exactly what it
needs to do we're not quite there yet
but from what you're saying we're we're
on the doorsteps of this sort of thing
and it's being used i mean some of the
new drugs that have come out for say
pancreatic cancer has been based on that
deep sequencing
of um multiple different types of
pancreatic cancer and um and i will say
you know
a family member
of mine is the benefit of that those new
drugs uh he was uh he was a type three
basically when you think about that and
is now in full remission because of the
technology and the ability to look at
multiple people very quickly and
multiple different types of strains to
personalize that medicine to help people
out now tell me you know i have
rudimentary
awareness and knowledge of dna
what does it mean to track mitochondrial
dna versus nuclear dna what what is
going on there when you guys uh pick and
choose what aspect of the molecule you
care about
so it's very quick uh so within your
body you have two types of dna and i
tell people to think of uh of a computer
the hard drive
is like the nucleus within your cell and
that's that hard drive tells your
computer what to do the operating system
and everything that's like the nuclear
dna
and that's those 23 pairs of chromosomes
you get half from mom half from dad
it tells you how fast you're going to go
white and if you're videotaping i
started going white at 25. how tall
you're going to be i've been trying to
go white my whole life
i think you mean gray i think you're
really right
my hair is white now
don't say whoa i didn't know people you
know michael jackson did that
and there's only one copy of that now
the um battery
of your computer gives it the energy
well within your cells you have
mitochondrion
they are the energy producing organelles
within and that has its own dna called
mitochondrial dna and that actually only
comes from the mother
and there's thousands of mitochondrial
copies per cell to that one nuclear
and so
where most labs focus on the nuclear dna
we actually focus on both of those
because it's about getting answers we
can use all of those
to help include or exclude individuals
to support identifications through the
dpaa before we let you go because we
we're going to continue this uh with
your a colleague um
tell me i i've read that
neanderthal dna
which you know we're now tens of
thousands of years ago is sometimes and
in some cases easier to extract than
some of the dna you're obtaining how's
that even possible
so uh actually that's a great question
so uh dr marshall who's the head of my
emerging technology we we've partnered
with the max planck institute
and we
in germany yep so we took uh we
partnered with them and took over some
of our chemically treated and they do a
lot of ancient dna but when you think
about that neanderthal dna a lot of it
is found in caves that are very deep
very cold very well preserved
and so
when we did the extractions and we
looked at the chemical damage and the
amount of human dna
in fact we were equivalent and damaged
to 40 35 to 40 000 year old neanderthal
dna
but the 20 samples that we took over
actually had less human dna
than the neanderthal and what we end up
doing is we end up having a lot of
bacterial dna
and we have we've had to figure out
methods to enrich for the human dna
so
i tell people to think the way we do
that is you know when you're walking
down the street if you saw that silver
dollar in the rain gutter you could put
a piece of gum on a stick and you could
stick it down and pick up that well we
developed methods that allowed us to
bind specifically the human dna and then
using those magnets pull the human dna
out from the bacterial dna by the way i
just just will let you know that uh uh
we have too much money to be worried
about a silver dollar in a drain
i thought you were better paid than that
tim we got to call it quits there but
thank you for joining us in this first
of three segments where we're exploring
the efforts of the department of defense
to to just do right by
missing soldiers and those who are
otherwise unidentified so uh tim dr
mcmahon thanks for joining us on star
talk
chuck and neil thanks very much for
having me it's been my pleasure um and
thanks for telling the story of our
families and our fallen heroes yeah
definitely we guarantee this will be
seen and heard far and wide we'll make
sure of it because we have power over
the
the
universe
the podcaster verse so up next we'll be
joined by forensic anthropologist
franklin damon who'll help us delve
deeper into the forensic science of it
all in the department of defense when
star talk continues
we're back star talk
we're talking about forensic science as
applied to
fallen soldiers in the department of
defense of the united states of america
and we were introduced to this
department i had never heard about the
dpaa
and we've got someone who is the deputy
director of that laboratory who is a
forensic anthropologist dr franklin
damon
dr damon welcome to star talk
thank you it's uh it's a pleasure to be
here it's a great opportunity
and in that first segment i think you
you might have eavesdropped on it uh we
made a quick mention of the uss oklahoma
could you just tell me give me a little
more details about
what went on there
because i thought that they were going
to leave the fallen sailors
navy personnel
entombed in the oklahoma
and that itself would be the burial site
so when did that change or did i not
remember that correctly
now you're correct as there's has been a
standard navy policy uh that uh the ship
goes down that is their their final
resting place is with the ship you see
that with uss arizona as a memorial out
of pearl harbor
you know the uss oklahoma's a little bit
different uh the sense that for four
years after that ship capsized
there were salvage operations so salvage
divers would go in underground
underwater into the ship
trying to find what they could what they
could find they buried in one of two
temporary cemeteries
it was the policy at the time that we're
not good the government is not going to
fight a global war and also identify and
repatriate the fallen soldier to the
server to the families that would take
place after the war
and so at the conclusion of world war ii
those two temporary cemeteries were
exhumed
and there was a laboratory a central
identification laboratory at schofield
barracks in uh in hawaii
where they attempted to uh segregate
these remains right it's dark and the
ship is capsized there's oil everywhere
they're just moving by by feel to try to
find what they can find but just to be
clear second world war was a segregated
army so the way you're using the word
throws me a little bit you meant just
you meant separate out the remains from
other things that could contaminate the
remains just to be clear that is correct
here we have uh 429 sailors and marines
that died on that ship right and after
four years there were what became
skeletonized remains became co-mingled
as the word that we use mixed with one
there you go
and that cemetery was it known in
advance that you would exhume what was
buried there
well no so they did their best to
identify what they could identify 35
service members at that time so can you
before you go any further
because when we when you talk about the
forensics of it
what is the
um kind of like regular uh investigative
identification
how's that done because 35 what makes
you if you're saying there's this
co-mingling how do you know that this 35
is indeed the 35
that's an excellent question you're
picking up on some of us here there's um
you know those 35 ids were made by
dental comparison
so each of these service members has a
medical history has a medical file and
it's really kind of important to
understand throughout any of our
identification effort is we can be the
best forensic anthropologist tim can
hire the best molecular biologist in his
lab right where you can squeeze dna out
of out of a bone and pull it out with a
magnet
but unless they have something to
compare it to if i have a dental
pattern in a set of remains i need that
anti-mortem that that in living you know
you go to the dentist and they record
your your restorations
your decay that's what i need to compare
to the remains to make an id and those
35 were all dental identifications wow
yeah if i can if i can say something
more fun even just fundamental about
science when we make any measurement in
the universe we need reference standards
against them otherwise it's just it's
just floating data with no way to even
think about it or to interpret it so
it's a way
more fundamental
reality in doing science than even just
in this application and that and that is
foundational across all of what we do in
this mission right we know what we know
about a population biology approach
right i know that if i measure a bone
this bone can tell me how tall a person
was
because i have a reference data set of
people that i know in life how tall they
were and i know their bone measurements
right so it's kind of a juxtaposition of
knowing the population biology and then
layering in all of these different data
points to then tease out what is an
individual from a population so that's
the anthropologist in you
wow
right it is indeed yeah yeah and so
so just remind me again just the
military practice because the oklahoma
did not sink
it came under a different category from
ships that do
because these were buried in the they
ultimately ended up in the national
cemetery the national memorial cemetery
the pacific at punchbowl in hawaii and
because those were in the cemetery i
think it made it a little easier to uh
to justify you also had one of the other
really cool things about what we do in
the government as
scientists is it's the kind of the apply
application of science to public right
it's public science in a way and that
we're doing this to meet a policy we're
doing it to meet a statute or law
and and here
when you have families family groups
that have demonstrated significant
interest and desire to have these cases
exhumed and analyzed and individually
identified i think carries a significant
amount of weight in our in our mission
of course definitely and so
uh just to make just to be clear uh
missing an action
um is
often
the person is presumed dead correct so
but the but the family doesn't know for
sure
and so even if they're confirmed dead
they want to be able to
at least have some kind of ceremony or
burial ritual to bring closure to this
this unknown is is that a fair
characterization of what what role
you're playing in this
in this in this journey from soldier to
memorial
i think that's absolutely fair i think
when you it's in our mission statement
when we say accounting for to account
for a missing person we're really we're
talking about telling their story like
who is that person and then providing
that family the primary next of kin the
information about their loss
even if we can't get ever to an
identification of somebody that's just
not going to happen we still have
information and research that our
historians have produced and
investigations and multiple attempts and
trying to do field archaeological
recoveries and all of that information
is is valuable to a family who's just
looking for
anything
so with respect to the story being told
and i hope this isn't too maroos
is there any other information that the
identification might be able to divulge
as a part of that story like i read
something about machu picchu where you
know they buried bones inside of these
tombs inside the mountain and they
pulled they pulled the bones out and
they realized that the diet of corn
like rotted most people's teeth it's
because it's very high in sugar but i
mean is there do people want to know
like
you know um
chuck chuck it was the candy bars in the
machine
at the commissary
the one that came down right exactly
that's that's something that gary larson
comic actually exactly right right um
but are there any other stories that can
be told the the the forensic story the
cause of death what right yeah sure
that's what i'm trying to say the cause
those those those uh uh markers
yeah so i think that's a really uh
there's a really cool connection between
what our historians do and our
researchers as they're looking into like
who's missing the over 80 000 that are
missing from from world war ii to our
wars in iraq
they're the ones who are charged with
doing the research to find out who they
are where were they last known to be
alive what what information do we have
about them and a lot of the time they're
looking at primary source documentation
secondary source of published books
about engagements and battles
and when you can marry that information
historical information secondary source
against what comes through the lab what
is recovered
who gets identified maybe you're
identifying a guy who historically was
said they were way up north
right and
but yet their body was found and we have
proven
the medical certainty that they were
down here you in a way can contribute to
the re-under to rewriting or
understanding
engagement right the battle and how the
movements of people
and time and space
so does this go back to the civil war
because a lot of battle you know a lot
of burial sites in battlefields because
they i think that was just before
they
could move a dead body without it
you know putrefying
to to its home back home so you buried
on the spot
so that's
is is that part of the mission statement
that you're undergoing here
yeah so our so the mission in statute
we're really looking from world war ii
to the iraq wars but the the the
logistics like the moving a body
um it had always been the policy up
until the korean war uh that it was
called uh you know temporary interment
you know bury that temporary cemetery
after a war we'd come back and exhume
you and identify you in fact it was
world war ii there was a massive program
it was called a return of the dead
program that picked up in 45. it was in
fact a curator at a place you may have
some familiarity with the american
museum of natural history who received a
letter from the quartermaster general of
the army who was responsible and said
okay now the war's over
i need help i don't know what to do
right oh okay and so
under invitation from the army harry
shapiro went over to europe looked at
some of the battlefields looked at what
was going on and said you know i think
you need to hire a bunch of
anthropologists
and so in europe they had european
anthropologists working in strasbourg in
hawaii all right you had a fellow by the
name of charles warren who was one of
the first anthropologists working for
the government
and
fulfillment of this mission
so so okay so that's a reminder
that
when you're on the frontier
of what is known and unknown you have to
sort of invent solutions that previous
people hadn't thought of right and so it
sounds so obvious today that of course
you bring in anthropologists because
they think about this stuff all the time
but in the service of these military
projects
that would have been a major
point of advance in terms of our
understanding of what's necessary it did
and and that policy changed as i crew
halfway through the korean war they
realized hell i would do a much better
job identifying these guys if i got them
back to a mortuary sooner god gotcha and
so that's when you have these places
start up in korea and and do concurrent
return is the policy that's what we've
been doing ever since that's what takes
place you know in iraq and afghanistan
so what's the best if you were to rank
environments in which
if you were to exhume a body
uh it's like the best environment for a
full recovery is it the desert
is it the jungle
or is it the time
the tundra is there no i no i let me
answer i know the best one
a glacier
freeze you in a glacier ice man iceman
that's the only one i know but uh any
anything else
you guys say great good news they're in
a bog or whatever so
what does an anthropologist say about
this
well you're right in the sense that uh
you're looking for environments that
don't change much
right you know in the earlier segment we
talked about neanderthal dna you heard
about neanderthal dna in these caves
where it's constant temperature moisture
and that does well for preservation of
organic material
one of the complicating factors in our
mission is that
we weren't necessarily fighting in bogs
or glaciers we do have cases that take
us out to glaciers aircraft losses but a
lot of them are are
airplane crashes and
uh skirmishes that take place in your
you know
the way in which the death event occurs
has a significant impact on what we can
actually recover you know if it's a
vietnam era jet aircraft as opposed to
a tank loss or a ground loss in europe
in world war ii
well that that's the question
what
what is the bare minimum that you would
need
in order to make an identification yeah
when we think of dna is it like a single
strand is it a you know a molecule i
mean how many
you know how many molecules dna
molecules do you need
most of the work that we're most of our
work does require dna
analysis and
if if evidence comes into the lab and i
have a large enough sample that i can
submit
we will and if it's successful we can
make an id and so right now we're
shooting for at least a minimum of two
grams of hard compact cortical bone
uh that we can send and just to remind
people two grams is not very much
all right that's like a tiny fraction of
an ounce
so
it's about the size of your the end of
your thumb wow
that's insane
right if we
if we had a tooth we'll pull the organic
material from the inside of a tooth and
send uh just milligrams of of powder
and what is the best
um material to receive the person walks
in and dies on the spot and then you can
identify them yeah well yeah and they
have their wallet on them and they tell
you their name and their id and their
dog tag and their social security
right then we good here we go
yeah you want something that's been
that's been pretty well preserved right
that's been in a pretty stable
environment that has large enough
samples that you can send off for dna
when you're talking about individual
bone types a lot of it has to do with
the in lab molecular techniques that
they use to prepare bone
you want to make sure you remove as you
know bone is a living tissue right it's
always it's constantly turning over it's
constantly uh changing
and uh it's porous
and so when it sits in the the
archaeological uh context it's taking on
those things like microbes and fungi and
all kinds of other decomposers that are
out there
and you want to be able to clean that
off as best you can and so usually we're
talking about those hard compact bone so
your your femur your upper leg bone some
of the uh internal structures of the
cranium your head
tend to be right around the ear the
inner ear area wow okay and now that you
said that about the the conditions
it just reminded me of the best place to
gather that information and i learned
this from neil
the moon
what are you talking about the movement
because you said that there are no
microbes to actually oh yeah you compose
a body correct correct that's right yeah
if you're if you're in a place that's
not organic there's nothing there's no
organic decomposition of you right it'll
just sort of stay there it might
desiccate but yeah definitely but i
don't think the dod is worried about
bodies on the moon chuck uh
that's not according to my conspiracy
theories
that means it's time to take a break and
when we get back
when we get back more with dr franklin
damon and we'll get deeper into his lab
and find out what are the methods tools
and tactics that he engages on this
edition this military edition of star
talk
we're back star talk i'm here with chuck
knight still tweeting at chuck nice
comic yes thank you sir yeah and i
noticed that your
uh brain games uh series dropped on
national g uh nat geo
and actually that's you find that
through disney i guess correct because
disney's
disney knows owns everything so just go
to disney you'll find whatever you're
looking for and now they own me
all right all right
i'm i'm slowly binging them as if that's
possible um but it's always good to see
what our human shortcomings are in our
capacity to think and interpret reality
that's sitting blatantly in front of us
[Laughter]
you want to know shortcomings that's
where i'm a viking
in this episode we've been addressing
the challenges and the triumphs of
identifying uh fallen heroes who
who were unknown who we only have
fragments of their bodies uh dna perhaps
but not always
and
we've got dr franklin damon uh who works
for the defense prisoner of war and
missing an action accounting agency and
so
so dr frankly could you just walk us
through
the the bureaucratic sequence of what
happens before a loved one or a family
member is notified of your success i
certainly can you know the 80 000 who
are missing uh from world war ii to the
wars in iraq um there are a couple ways
in which we find evidence and get it
into the laboratory really it starts
with our uh model as uh researchers and
analysts go find out who's missing that
launches a team out to do an
investigation talk to witnesses hey what
did you what do you know did you see a
plane crash here 30 40 years ago yeah
that's right here uh that leads into
either an excavation of a site if you're
out in the jungle somewhere on the side
of the oshawa valley in vietnam or if
you're looking into remains that the
government already owns in a national
cemetery somewhere across europe where
they will recover the attempted id but
they couldn't do an id
they're buried as under a headstone that
says unknown we have all of those
records and what can we do today with
our science today to put a name to that
set of remains
once that happens it comes into the
laboratory and that's when our
laboratory procedures take place we have
a lab out in hawaii our main lab in
hawaii we have one here in nebraska
and we've got about 150 staff working
this this mission and everything from
anthropologists and dentists data
scientists uh forensic chemists
uh doing the work to uh
combine as much information as possible
about a set of remains so that our group
of case coordinators can look at who's
missing and try to match up that
postmortem information that's collected
what we call in the blind so they know
nothing about a case as it comes in and
they just look at the evidence and
produce the report and their information
and then another set of people look at
it and match it up against who's missing
and that's when our medical examiner
says
yes
everything matches up and this is this
person beyond any other reasonable
possibility
and then you get you get the the
military person that goes to the door
and rings the bell i mean that we see in
movies and how do you how how do you
notify the kin
once once the medical examiner makes the
identification that notification goes to
the respective service casualty officer
so if it's army goes to army navy goes
navy
that service casualty officer in turn is
the responsible party for communicating
to the family within 24-48 hours they'll
initiate a phone call to say hey
we now have identified the remains of
your relative
and that then leads into a series of
conversations about you know where
they're going to be buried when they
want to be buried
and and everything kind of is back
planned from there
so this is like one of the most
collaborative projects i've ever heard
of in any and anything i mean
the chemist the biologist the medical
doctor like you said the dentist the
anthropologist and the historians this
is a this is a brilliant use of academic
resources and as an academic
fundamentally i think this is a
beautiful uh beautiful reality you have
created yeah the only thing that's
missing is uh david caruso from csi
miami no but no what he's saying is way
harder than anything csi has ever had to
tackle i'm looking at csi now oh you all
got it easy
you guys make this see it's trying to
have their own tv show no we need the
dps that's what it is
oh my gosh yeah csi is like the romper
room of what you do
those guys are like they're like
kindergarten
yeah we got the body it was shot right
here on this street corner you know i
got what do we have on these guys look
at these guys you're like what do you
want a cookie god everything was already
done for you right
so
that's called we call that csi effect
right that's actually a real thing that
we contend with and talking to families
and trying to get them to understand
that sometimes it's not always so easy
it doesn't happen in the 45 minutes and
there's no commercial breaks so the
so people are actually biased by the
fact that they watch this kind of
representation of the science and
technology play out in this tiny little
short period of time yeah yeah i believe
so wow
that means everybody's and everybody's
young and good looking and you know the
whole thing is what
aren't we
i was waiting for it
that one was too that was too easy that
was too easy
um so so franklin is there
um i'm intrigued by what role
the moving frontier of ai and and
machine learning and
big data might play in your work because
that's that that stuff changes weekly
right and if you want to take full
advantage of it somebody in your office
needs to be tracking that so what role
does that play now and what role do you
see that can play for the future
yeah we're just beginning to scratch the
surface of it and i think it's going to
be huge for us as we continue to move
forward uh really right now we're just
doing very simple simple what i call
simple ai i think is referred to
normally where we're just looking to
automate
boring tasks that you would normally
have an anthem you know i've got a board
certified forensic anthropologist that's
working
and if they're spending a lot of their
time just messing around with an excel
spreadsheet and playing with data you
know that's not
that's not really living up to their
what they went to school for and it's my
job to put them in front of the bench on
the table working with the remains and i
can have my data scientists work with
these spreadsheets to automate some of
the work
an example of what we've done
we've talked about the uss oklahoma
when those uh
i think there were 62 graves that were
exhumed and they came here into the
laboratory first thing we do is a full
inventory so that's just right out every
bone that comes in we had over 13 000
individual bone specimens that came into
the lab
that we needed to segregate into
individuals from a commingled assemblage
um back into you know what is one person
when i got here in 2015
we were walking around with clipboards
and a government skill craft pen
collecting the you know our inventory
which made it awfully difficult to do
any downstream work with
and so through our partnership
initiative that dpaa was allowed to do
we worked with university of nebraska at
ohio in the college of information
science and technology
and built a database that allows us to
to have multiple users use it
we've got standards
it's cloud-based
the data that goes in gets peer-reviewed
within the system and there's you know
it's uh we've got security layers over
the top of it
and uh the nice part is because it's
standardized we can then
work with the data in a very simplified
way where i can search and filter and
start looking at pulling that data out
and say
take all of my 13 000 specimens that are
in this space and put them in this
graphical space
and then let me look at relationships
and associations between left bones and
right bones and if i take my standard
measurements across one bone we're all
pretty bi uh pretty symmetrical right
bilaterally left to right we're all as
humans we're pretty symmetrical
on the outside yeah right right yeah but
mostly on the inside too yeah yeah
mostly but yeah you have one pancreas
and one liver you know right and one
heart but yeah yeah otherwise right
right
and so uh we can look at uh automating
the comparison so if i have
traditionally if i'm looking at an upper
arm bone onto the left i need to compare
it to 300 writes i mean that's i have to
do that like one to 300 but i have to do
it 300 times because i got 300 left to
go at and it takes an analyst like a
full week to do that work
but if i have the measurements and i can
run them through my automation
software
i can focus on the tails the people that
are excluded right
and just focus on those 20 and my
analysts can do those in the morning but
we also are moving into 3d technology
surface scanning looking at you know
everything so far is just
two-dimensional measurements looking at
linear measurements but now we're
looking at uh actual surface models
volumetric yeah excellent
what is the clavicle method i've read
about that what is that yeah so that's
something you know we're looking at
x-ray comparisons that's all we're doing
we're looking at post-mortem after death
to pre-anti-motive before death images
and much like you go to the dentist and
you would have a dental x-ray we have
the same thing from these service
members except they're not teeth or
clavicles you're a collarbone
right we have
service members in the 40s and 50s would
show up to these medical clinics and
have chest x-rays taken to look for
tuberculosis right are you fit for
service
so you got the you got the clavicle for
free so
out of that data set so here's our
here's our massive data set of
anti-mortem chest radiographs that we
have access to and not only do we have
access to them because it's the military
there's a very particular technical
manual that defines how you're supposed
to take that image so you know exactly
how far they are away from you know the
subject from the capture device how
they're standing
all of that information and we can
recreate that so we go out and we exhume
an unknown we have uh the the bones of
the neck and we have the collarbones
and we can position them into a couple
of different triage
a couple different positions and we can
take an x-ray and then what we do is we
take the x-ray against maybe our list of
five people we think it could be and we
start looking for pattern matches right
i'm looking at the the densities the uh
the opacity within the x-ray itself to
see where am i finding or excluding
someone from from that match to the
remains okay this sounds like the you
know we already have face recognition
software so now we just need clavicle
recognition software and then you can
automate that you know just fine
we have part of the original uh research
development was to look at all of these
anti-mortam x-rays and look at how
unique the shape is just the shape of
the shaft of the clavicle not even the
the part where it comes out know that
and that isn't we can run an automated
search that returns you know your top 10
hit list of like who who this possibly
could be based off of the shape of your
clavicle now the clavicle is not the
strongest bone in the body in fact i i i
used to wrestle and in high school i
actually broke a guy's collarbone um i
took him down in a
in a takedown pin
there's some takedowns that are also a
pin maneuver when you hit when you hit
the mat
what high school did you go to cobra kai
cobra county high school
sweep the leg
sweep the leg
no no but but
by got when it cracked the whole room
heard it it was like there it is in his
body and like
it was like oh my gosh like what just
happened so
so but i have this this
this relationship to the collarbone that
i didn't really want to have so that was
i'm a little more sensitive to what
you're describing for it yeah you think
you're sensitive you should see the guy
you broke his club against
having broke my own once as a child i
it's not a fun experience
well so ted we gotta land this plane can
you tell us
um what can we expect in the next five
years ten years based on your crystal
ball read of the science the direction
science is going
and and also geopolitical cooperation in
this exercise seems to be paramount
yeah two totally different questions
there i'll i'll hit the innovation one
first and where we're going i think
uh the biggest thing that we've got
doing going on right now in our research
area and what we're looking to validate
is the use of stable isotopes as tracers
you know and this is uh you know we're
looking primarily at uh carbon carbon
1213 looking at
ratios
that we're finding in remains in order
to
differentiate on whether somebody is of
a possible u.s origin or
or not and is this something that i need
to to send off to to uh dr mcmahon and
after to run a dna sample or is it one
that i don't need to be concerned about
because it's not part of our mission set
by the way in my field isotope ratios
are everything
when we have a rock a meteorite that
doesn't match other meteorites in the
asteroid belt that we have we can trace
them to and someone went into a pocket
of air inside of it and noticed that the
isotope ratios of the gas equaled the
what you find in the atmosphere of mars
and it became the first unambiguously
martian identified um uh meteorite
because of isotope ratios so i
m my people know full well the power of
isotope ratios so the power to you as
you bring that to your field yeah and
it's you know it's all based on what you
eat right what we figured out many years
ago the chemist and the c3c4 plants and
and how the carbons are being
incorporated
one question i have for you everything
that we're we're doing here uh is is
tied to what is known in the ratios here
on earth
you know and i guess your comment um
what are the i what do we know of the
isotopic ratios of 12 and 13 and other
stars or
planets yeah there's some places where
there's only carbon 12 and carbon 13 is
extremely rare but in your case there
are other isotope ratios that changed in
the era of
of nuclear weaponry right so
so if you were in a place and a time
there's certain in your bones and your
calcium there's you have different
ratios than if you were in a different
place at a different time so unless it's
glowing
first indication you were at a nuclear
bomb test
and that's how we're using them as
tracers exactly
um no so wow so that's a that's a very
fertile field this sounds like you're
just beginning to to tap into so uh so
about there now tell me just
geopolitically how this how that works
yeah so you know um our our men and
women who have fought for the country
have uh not just died here in the united
states but it's all over the globe
and our mission requires that we
interface with other nations
there are about 46 50 different nations
that we deal with and i work with i
shouldn't say deal with but we have
proper cooperative relationship on a
daily basis um
you know and i think that's you know
part of our our mission set that doesn't
really get mentioned of much is the
humanitarian nature yes and the the
geopolitical relationships uh that we
are able to establish through this
mission
in fact it was uh
one of our former former president and
then his interactions uh with north
korea and the four points that were
raised uh the four fourth point there
was this mission and
turning over uh remains of missing u.s
service members uh that were in the
possession of the north koreans
so this is this is hopeful and plus what
it tells us is even where
where relations might be tense
there's a deeper humanity in what it is
you do
that perhaps you would like to believe
at least
permeates all nations of the world
yeah that's uh i like to think of it as
is
exactly in those terms right that i i'm
a human
we're all humans we all have basic core
needs and beliefs and
you know i'm a i'm a son i'm a husband
i'm a i'm a brother and and so were they
and so are the folks that we we talk to
and work with and it makes it uh easy to
understand i think
well
dr damon
um it's been an honor to have you on
this program representing such an
important uh branch of what is going on
at the department of defense that that
hardly anybody knows about i mean i
didn't know about it but i don't know
that i should be am i representative i
don't know
of of the knowledge base of
americans and of this world but uh to
the extent that we couldn't
get people to see and hear this podcast
we will do it i've always been a big fan
likewise
all right uh dr franklin damon thank you
for your time and how do we find out
more about your is there a web page that
we can go to for the dpa
absolutely uh
dpaa.mill and we also have a page on
facebook uh a new twitter uh account as
well
but not yet tick-tock okay you got to
work on that
get the youngins involved
yeah i'll call your people we'll figure
out what we can do there excellent
all right uh again thank you dr damon uh
chuck nice always good to have you man
always a pleasure all right i am neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always beating you to
keep looking up
[Music]
you